hey guys it is Friday which means I've
got five of this week's very best
stories in gaming all ready to go for
you so let's get going first up for
Thursday couldn't manage to wrestle the
word Scrolls off of merging but they
have kept a developer from using the
word fallout in their game title indie
game fortress fallout came under fire
from Bethesda once the game development
giant became aware that indie studio
ex-real intended to give their game a
name with the word all out in it despite
the fact that fortress fallout is a 2d
iOS tower defense game but they'll still
concern that it would create confusion
over whether the title was somehow
connected to the Fallout series at the
end of the day the people with all the
money one out and plenty of you pondered
whether you should trademark the word
thug and start suing left right and
center
the drama over the order 1886 is Lake
was rampant this week and here's how it
all ended after days upon days of
speculation as to how long the thing was
with the YouTube playthrough finishing
it in around five hours and the dev
later saying it was closer to eight to
ten it might not have mattered the
review scores of landed and reception
has been mixed to put it nicely
developer ready at dawn did their best
to justify that they were shooting for
quality over quantity which is fair
enough but if you take our reviewer
kevin van towards work for it it seems
they may have missed the mark on both of
those goals as for things you can get on
the cheap this week the Xbox ultimate
game sales about halfway through and
comes with plenty of savings the seven
day sale is loaded with discounts on
dozens of games across xbox one and xbox
360 among the xbox one collection you
can get alien isolation or watch dogs
for 24 bucks shadow of Mordor for 30
advanced warfare destiny or the croutha
just over forty dollars or the telltale
games collection for 55 bucks xbox 360
offerings include a lot of games for
less than five dollars including batman
arkham city Mass Effect the orange box
Dark Souls and dragon age 2 you can
check out the full list of cheap stuff
on gamespot
another group of Kickstarter backers are
bracing for impact this week as lead
developer of the stomping land Alex
Pandora appears to have abandoned his
project for something land was a
survival game featuring dinosaurs that
was funded for a hundred and fourteen
thousand dollars after asking for only
20 grand as it stands a birth of the
game is available on early access but it
seems it might never make it to a full
release against art lead has quit to
work on other projects as both key and
the in-game model designer have been
unable to get in touch with creator Alex
wanderer for over a month finally there
was some talk / Sony abandoning the Last
Guardian trademark this week but it
appears all as well the game's trademark
was abandoned but it seemed somebody
just forgot to renew it since Sony have
said The Last Guardian ear still in
development Sony have now filed to
revive the abandoned trademark
application which they've been extending
since 2013 The Last Guardian has now
been in development for more than half a
decade after its formal announcement in
2009 when will actually get a look at
the thing though is anybody's guess let
me know down in the comments if you're
keen to play the last guardian or if
there's another mi a title that you're
holding out hope for personally I'd
really like to hear from beyond good and
evil to this week on sites check out my
gist episode on games we have a
love-hate relationship with we review
the order 1886 and skyrim mods takes to
the skies of Tamriel those it for me
this week as always do let me know what
you cared about and I'll catch you again
on Monday
you
you